c'est quelque chose qui a été fait il y
a quelques années suite à l'ouragan en
ou normalement les oiseaux comme ici à
Québec puis vont quitter à la fin où là
les derniers jours de où c'est difficile
de trouver des matières à Québec et puis
cette année-là en 2005 il y a eu un gros
ouragan qui est passé par les Antibes
qui remontaient jusqu'à la Nouvelle
Écosse si bien que à la fin octobre
début novembre mon nouvel Écosse ils ont
trouvé plein de martinets certains
encore vivants mais plusieurs morts donc
l'ouragan avait ramené les martinets
vers le nord en arrivant bien sûr dans
les dans les Maritimes il faisait froid
je pense faisait autour de 6 degrés
c'est sûr que les insectes étaient plus
présents donc la majorité des oiseaux
ont dû mourir on pense que plusieurs
milliers d'oiseaux sont premiers moments
donc les ouragans c'est sûr peuvent
avoir un effet important sur non
seulement sur une bonne partie de la
population
mais on ne peut évaluer